on the
attack so don't don't lean forward with
the we on front so we're both in a in a
mutual stance I now bring
over and I
cut it covers the Rest by about 7 cm he
releases me I lift and he enters he
should feel comfortable on he should be
5050 on his feet I watch him as he holds
me
off and and then I cut here slightly
around this way then this means it will
cut my whole head
off if we don't do that if I if I Just
Step
straight if I Just Step straight this
what happens and it only Nicks the the
neck this is incorrect so when he pulls
back for the wrist he'll
now exactly so it throws out all all the
measurements okay so he releases
me and then
here
so so these are the points that are
important we'll just change camera
angles
okay
so so it doesn't matter who adjusts as
long as we get to this point
here so I'm going to like letting air
out of a
balloon this is the F
so watch the front foot it it operates
through out my
body it doesn't it doesn't just lift and
then I step forward I'm connected all
the way through my
body here and I adjust
back wrist releases the wrist I lift and
I watch him
and I watch him and I step slightly and
that's what makes
the go through my NE on on the sord when
he slides back now he moves his body not
just his arm G this needs to be
controlled releases
me nor SL
but it might be a big slide back and you
get this problem so it means in this
case he wasn't
connected um sens sensory wise because
if it had been it would have been like a
piece of
string it would have been like a piece
of string